hey guys i'm ryan right Alyssa be crazy
valentine's Day is approaching us this
week so I thought why not give you guys
our top five favorite romantic comedies
all around home i'm here with alyssa be
crazy so we're gonna take turns giving
our top five no no my number five is
Groundhog Day plastic movie bill murray
curly-haired actress forgot her name
used to be famous it's just a great
movie it's really funny it's a classic
it's more of a comedy than a rom-com but
there is a strong romantic comedy
element to it and it is so [ __ ] funny
Bill Murray is awesome i would love to
repeat the same day over and over again
does that be the master of picking up
prostitutes I number five is just go
with it Adam Sandler surprisingly
Jennifer Aniston also brooklyn decker
and a cameo done by Nicole Kidman it is
surprisingly funny it's one of those
once you look at your like I don't know
about it but then you watch it and you
laughed your butt off the entire time
there are two kids involved and those
kids make the movie everything they say
is just like laughing so hard you're
like holding your rear ribcage worthy
number my number four is when harry met
sally it's a story about two best
friends of 10 years who fell in love
just like Veronica and I oh it's a great
movie the chemistry is undeniably
they're hilarious it's a great
commentary film really captures what
it's like when your two friends who end
up sleeping together which is awesome my
number four is 50 first dates I'm sure
all of you have seen it by now also adam
sandler which is surprising because i'm
actually not a huge adam sandler fan I
just thought like certain movies of
those that are similar i guess and also
drew Barrymore I love her it's about guy
who moves to the island or we kill us on
the island anyway she has amnesia and
short-term memory loss and she'd like
doesn't forget that she knows this guy
but he like is so dedicated to being in
love with her he just he doesn't even
care and he makes it work it's magical
it has a great ending and as a walrus
it's great ending really does tuck in my
heart that
does number are number three and then we
both have this as a number three crazy
stupid love I love me a good Ryan
Gosling film me and he proved he can do
comedies very well when it came to that
story this film I thought was just a
magical experience I had a great time
watching it Steve Carell awesome in it
Ryan Gosling also awesome in it it's got
like several different love stories
going on a little kid too it's really
felt like the chemistry of the actors is
great it's just a really good time and I
love how it's actually real like it
plays on the chemistry of each character
and how they all interact man you really
can identify with each of the characters
cuz at some point growing up you
experience something any of the
characters have felt at some point
during the film and I love how they all
cross over and they all interact with
each other sooner or later it had that
very Valentine's idées feel absolutely
number two and I number two's to
graduate I wouldn't know if you would
consider this a romantic comedy but it
was that film that I saw when I was
really young where I really felt the
romance I really feel the love in this
film I love how there's a sexual story
and then there's a love story I think
that it captures love in a really
interesting way by the time it ends you
don't know it's not like it's happily
ever after like you don't know what
journey they're going to embark on but
it's worth taking that chance my number
two is pretty woman if you haven't seen
it that's a big mistake huge it's
probably one of the most popular
romantic stories ever made first off
just because it's Richard year and Julia
Robertson they are such a dynamic duo I
mean they work together so many times
for a good good reason it's the classic
cinderella story you know going up poor
I don't really have anything that's
falling in love the [ __ ] it's a daily
struggle daily struggle no one my number
one is Notting Hill I just adored the
[ __ ] out of that movie the chemistry
between a celebrity and he like when
Hugh Grant was in his prime of doing
these rom-coms it was just amazingly
fantastic Julia Roberts is creating it
Hugh Grant is great in it I forgot the
other actors name but he's
roommate of hugh grant he's really funny
it's a movie that's really built off the
chemistry of an average Joe and a
celebrity falling in love with each
other it feels so authentic at the same
time it's like a fantasy but it really
does work and my number one is how to
lose a guy in 10 days I love this movie
it's like just the perfect amount of
cheese where it's like just so so
delicious you just you fall in love with
the characters and the characters are
kind of vicious towards each other
they're actually not gonna lie but
that's what makes you fall in love with
them even more is that they're just at
each other's throats so much you're
rooting for both of them at the same
time which is rare I think that you find
any movie because you're either rooting
for one side or the other and the
chemistry just is so amazing you're
really great rom coms are mainly built
up the chemistry of the main actors and
I think in all these movies we listed
the chemistry is really good oh
definitely I know your number five is
just go with it I think it's one of the
greatest films but i still can't deny
the fact that Adam Sandler and Jennifer
Aniston have a pretty good chemistry
surprisingly yeah that's what those
tools that you look at again and you're
just not really sure about it they
really proved a point with that what I
think well anyway guys that's our top
five favorite rom-coms what are your top
five favorite rom-coms if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and you can check out a
list of me crazies channel who just did
a vlog with none other than Shane the
Dawson so check that video out there'll
be a link of the description box so yeah
this would be crazy it was [ __ ] is
getting crazy I know I want to be in a
rom-com anyone I want to be about a guy
who gets like genital herpes hmm and
meets a fat woman who accepts him for
who he is because she's fat and she has
no one else you know yeah I'm sure a lot
of people can identify with that you
should really go after that capitalize
on it make it work herpa fattest that's
what I'm fallin brilliant herpa fattest
he has a genius mind what if a guy with
herpes and a fat girl fell in love herp
offense